here is one of American industry's greatest
challenges today the challenge of a growing
changing ever expanding nation more people more
homes more raw materials more jobs how do we
provide for all these things and the vastly
increased quantities expected over the next
few years nineteen seventy five it's predicted
that our population will be way past 200 million
instead of 50 million automobiles crowding
our highways there will be 80 million or more
the output of US factories will
be just about double what it is
now thanks largely to automation our
consumption of raw materials water
electricity petroleum lumber metals
and so on will be up accordingly
all of the poses some tremendous problems
now occupying the attention of a great many
American industrialists who feel that on their
success or failure in contending with those
problems under our free enterprise system
may defend the continuation of our way of
life for they other than if we were to run
short of food or coal or steel or any other
essential item our whole complex economy might
be crippled or brought to a stop for example
what about transportation more specifically
truck transportation an important element in
every industry will it be adequate to the needs
of nineteen seventy five today trucks handle
three out of every four tons of freight moving
in American Commerce they provide a market for
the things we all produce while at the same
time bringing to us in trucks designed for
their own specific purposes the things turned
out by others everything from milk to gasoline
raw materials and finished goods farm produce
and the output of our mines mills and factories
take an agricultural product like
oranges from groves all over our
orange producing states the fruit is rushed
at the peak of quality to centrally located
processing plants and then on to consumers
throughout the land modern transportation
has helped make our food industry
the marvelously efficient machine
it is today and will surely be just as
vital to this industry in the years ahead
of course food is just one of the many
types of products hauled in this manner
some things are hauled in almost no other way
for example household effects the moving ban
has become familiar on every Highway
and byway as it goes about its job of
transporting families most personal possessions
swiftly and safely any distance door-to-door
in fact the service is even better than
door-to-door most moving companies now
we'll come in and pack your Goods transport
them then unpack them again at the other end
generally the big intercity moving vans are
owned and operated by local businessmen who band
together in Nationwide associations in this free
economy of ours only in order to link every corner
of the country making it possible for a family
to move easily from any point to any other point
not only does the trucking industry thus
extend its own services into every county
of the US it similarly extends the services of
other types of carriers by making the original
pickup or the final delivery trucks also
make it possible for every one of us to
use carriers that unlike trucks cannot go
everywhere let's follow this truck loaded
with lumber to its destination a factory
in which homes are being mass-produced on
a Detroit style assembly line basis this one
company produces roughly one out of every 50
new homes being built in this country today
and watching them it's not hard to see how
they do it as America grows at a rate that's
almost explosive such techniques for providing
the housing we'll be needing are bound to be
expanded and of course truck transportation
really makes this operation possible for
trucks not only bringing the raw materials
they also carry the mass-produced elements of
each new home directly to the construction site
in one trailer the Macon's for one house and
thus far in the company's comparatively short
history it has delivered more homes than there
are in all of San Francisco or Minneapolis
well over 25,000 cities and towns are served
by no means of transport other than trucks
this full cargo of course is headed for
one destination so there is virtually no
routing problem but in the case of less than
full cargo freight shipments complex systems
have been worked out to eliminate delays
and keep the merchandise speeding on its
way truck terminals at key locations all
across the country permit the regrouping
of consignments bound for the same
destination aboard the same trucks
here also has done the maintenance
work on the rolling stock maintenance
work that minimizes the chance of
delays caused by breakdowns on route
here to the companies carry on the employee
training programs that give the industry
its widespread and well-deserved
reputation for safety and courtesy
among industrial executives an important
fact of life is the way in which our
booming population is dispersing
itself to the suburbs and beyond
many millions of our citizens have
fled the noise the congestion and
other inconveniences of city life
in order to set up housekeeping in
homes of their own out in the wide
open spaces beyond the water main
these Americans on the move have also taken
enthusiastically to a new way of shopping
and millions of our citizens not only live
in the country now they work there too in
factories and offices built way out where even
fifty or hundred acre plants are economically
feasible many of these industrial plants and
the housing projects and shopping areas that
depend on them for economic sustenance can
be served only by highway by automobile bus
and truck this is a trend that is expected
to continue already of motorists driving
from Boston to Washington will see very little
open countryside he passes almost continuously
through interconnected communities in effect
it's one big long strip city students of city
growth tell us that as the flight to the
suburbs continues the nation's population
will be heavily concentrated in 14 such strip
cities one will extend from st. Louis up to
Chicago and Milwaukee then over to Detroit down
to Toledo and east to Cleveland and Pittsburgh
another from San Francisco and Sacramento
down to Los Angeles and San Diego
a third from Jacksonville to Orlando then
branching out down both the east and west
coasts of Florida since 1951 8 out of every
10 new factories put up have been built on
sites away from the large cities the trend
is on and in the years to come the demands
to be placed on the trucking industry
can hardly be exaggerated for just this
one factory for example try to imagine
how many thousands of truck deliveries
will be necessary to keep its machines
turning and its employees on the payroll
one reason industries and families often
gear for moving to the wide-open spaces is
to get away from congestion but only
through proper and adequate planning
by industry can they avoid
taking congestion with them
industrial executives know better than most
people perhaps that good circulation is as
important to the community as it is to the
human body provisions for good circulation are
being made in projects like New York's Lincoln
Square and other well thought-out developments
off street parking adequate access road
separation of local and through traffic
these are just a few of the ways
of assuring that a new industrial
park or shopping center or even a whole
community will reach its full potential
people must be able to travel quickly
and easily from home to work to shops
to schools to recreation and to see
each other professionally and socially
Goods must move quickly and inexpensively
to and from the outside world from warehouse
to retailer to consumer and also from
factory to factory if they can't move
all the promises our system holds
for 1975 could come to nothing our
expanded population would only mean less of
everything for everybody rather than more
many shiny new communities without adequate
traffic planning could become the slums of
the future on the outskirts of almost any city
in the country you'll find places where it's
happening already who for example wants
to sit out on one of these front lawns
industry as always in any sphere affecting
the development of our country takes the
initiative in seeing to it that the
built in flights are eliminated in
advance while there's still time no one
appears to have all the answers to the
problems facing a country expanding as
rapidly as ours but industry is doing
its utmost to find those answers you can be
sure the answers will be found and that the
changing face of a truly free America will
be worthy of the rich promise of the future